this morning on the dish as you may be
preparing for your socially distanced
labor day barbecue
we're taking you to a place few people
ever get to see
inside a president's kitchen chef
matthew wendell went from his small town
in texas to cooking for world leaders as
an aide to president george w
bush his story and his recipes are now
available in his new cookbook
recipes from the president's ranch chris
van cleeve met up with him
at wendell's outdoor kitchen are you
sure i can handle this
anyone can make burgers this way we'll
see about that
while the burger is a labor day staple
it's one i've
never made from scratch when i walk down
here the first thing i do is look around
and look for the microwave
i notice we're not using the microwave i
don't even own a microwave
you don't own a microwave no old fashion
so a cook i am not fortunately mr old
fashioned here matthew wendell
very much is he never set out to be a
chef
but has been working in the kitchen
since he was a kid a love of food born
from helping his mother velva
cook for his eight siblings as soon as
we were
old enough to sit on the counter and
stir something she thought that if you
could cook you would never go hungry and
you could always find a job
it would be years and a couple of career
changes later while working as a caterer
in austin when he befriended then texas
governor george w
bush and his wife laura about a year
before
bush announced he was running for
president he asked wendell who he calls
maddie
if he'd come with him to washington were
there points when you were
there that you're like how did i end up
here i always told mrs bush
it's surreal i mean i'm just a cook
learned in my mother's kitchen and
you're having me cook for all these very
important people
and she said that's the way we want it
like the book says
food people like to eat in maddie's new
cookbook recipes from the president's
ranch
food people like to eat this soft-spoken
small-town texan
takes us on his unlikely but very tasty
journey from washing dishes in the back
of phillips and danbury texas
to the oval office and the kitchens at
camp david
and president bush's crawford texas
ranch revealing these pictures few have
seen before
what was president bush's favorite meal
i would say dessert
crawford was the bush family's retreat
from washington when they were at the
ranch
wendell was in the kitchen making meals
like the one he made for us
from recipes he's now sharing with
everyone at the urging
of the former first lady today we're
having the smokey cheeseburgers
pasta salad fried chicken of course some
salsa and chips that made the salsa
a lower bushes peach cream pie and my
chocolate chip cookies
and the chocolate chip cookies these
were a staple
a staple president's ranch every time we
went to the ranch or camp david
we had to have cookies the ranch became
a key part of presidential diplomacy
hosting world leaders like russian
president vladimir putin
british prime minister tony blair and
mexican president vincente fox
often it was wendell's food that brought
them together
you're making some of these meals for a
world leader do you feel some extra
pressure there not any more pressure
than i would if i were having friends
over
actually really surprisingly because you
are just so busy
cooking the food you don't have time to
think about the power of the guests
this stunning photo captures german
chancellor angela merkel
grilling him about barbecuing the beef
tenderloin i just learned
through the years just enjoy the moment
and not be intimidated by
anyone because she showed such an
interest and
wanted to know my techniques so she
could maybe duplicate them
among the 54 recipes from the
president's ranch the sweet and smoky
cheeseburger became a staple of what was
dubbed president bush's
cheeseburger diplomacy my food brought
people together countries together
even though you have different views
you're sharing the same food under the
same table
so there's something equalizing about
that nothing else you can talk about the
food
right everybody loves food everyone has
to eat
president bush wasn't the first
president to use uniquely american meals
to forge a bond with world leaders
franklin roosevelt served the king and
queen of england hot dogs at his new
york home in 1939
and president barack obama wasn't afraid
to adopt bush's cheeseburger diplomacy
with russia's dmitry medvedev but he
didn't have wendell so they ate out
the recipes like his mother's hot rolls
or sunday night stacked cheese
enchiladas are straightforward and
approachable
even if you don't really spend much time
in the kitchen which brings us back to
making those burgers
the trick is mixing in the barbecue
sauce before shaping the patties
resulting in a smoky taste and less mess
when you're eating don't be nervous
says the guy who wrote a cookbook laura
bush liked a thin
patty and sharp cheddar cheese thin like
that
so that like that a little thinner throw
the burgers on the grill for a few
minutes at medium heat
add the cheese this smells so good i
need to do more food stories
and it's about time to eat if i can just
get them
off the grill can you tell i spend a lot
of time in the kitchen
well there are other jobs to do with the
burgers finally on the plate
it was time to eat try the pasta salad
too and
eat we did this is fantastic my mother
said always put a little love into
whatever you make so
that's what i try to do oh love him
christmas welcome to our dish yeah and
that's it
don't be thinking like you're going to
take all our great dishes
anything it's good that's cause yeah i
mean it was great yeah no it was
fantastic we love ourselves it is food
diplomacy good stuff learned a lot